he is none other than Pro Football Hall
of Famer Jerry Rice also here courtesy
of our friends from San Francisco in
rice a roni rice and pasta Roni if you
will good to chat with you Jerry Rice
how are you sir
rich how you doing better for talking to
you man oh man
it's good to hear your voice right back
at you how was it to be a correspondent
for NFL to grind watching and following
around Larry this passage it was so good
you know because we always grunting
that's one thing about us and then to be
able to give the fans and exclusive
inside the head of one of the greatest
receivers to ever play the game with
Larry Fitzgerald so I had opportunity to
be on the field and this guy he was just
everything everything that I thought you
know he was well but one thing they rich
here's the deal yes doing the entire
time on the field it's like when they
were warming up Larry kept throwing me
the football so you know it's like when
the team is running drills like that to
warm up you know pregame and all that
then he would throw me the ball and he
just kept coming over so you know I was
just hoping that he he broke the record
and he was able to you know catch five
balls and pass Tony Gonzalez which
toning is he was an exceptional tight in
he plays a game certain weight and you
know it was great to see Larry
accomplished that and becomes second now
Jerry what what just try and put a mere
mortal that's listening to us or
watching us right now in the shoes of of
what makes Larry so great that you know
because you embodied that greatness
yourself it's a difference between being
good and great in them as a difference
it's being great and and one of the
all-time greats Jerry what what is that
intangible you know I think the thing is
is having a
nation of so many different things so
many different qualities his hands he
doesn't drop footballs the way he can
run route and routes and position
himself it's another thing his knowledge
about the game of football his also his
mentorship of passing the game on to
other players so I think he's a great
ambassador for the game of football and
I'll throw that in a bill Jerry Rice
here on the Rich Eisen show who is in
your mind the second greatest receiver
of all time oh my god rich why you put
me on the spotlight cause it's my job
Jerry and I'm also very curious people
would and I don't think you're you know
denigrating anybody else but who's
number one we know who is Jerry you know
uh you know man I put Larry Fitzgerald
up there you know you know he's uh he's
still playing at a very high level I you
know I love his approach to the game the
way he condition the waiting condition
himself he's always in tough shape he's
gonna go out and and always give it 100%
I would have to say Larry Fitzgerald man
and who was the toughest that you ever
faced guarding you Deion Sanders and
Darryl Greene two of the fastest
cornerback terrible play the game so it
was important for me to just try to win
at the line of scrimmage if I had the
double move triple move and try to get
them off their base because when you got
to fast cornerbacks like that what they
want you to do is just release because
they they knew that they could run with
you and and so I would have to give it
to those two guys one of my favorite
lines having been around Deon as long as
I have Jerry Rice is at the combine when
he watches cornerbacks in the weight and
reps room have to pull
up 225 pounds as many times as possible
he laughs just like that saying it's
ridiculous he goes I never had to put
Jerry Rice across my chest and lift him
that's the line he always uses yeah you
know Beyond and I we had some great
battles and you know we still talk about
those days and the thing that comes to
mind is so weird because when we had to
face each other we didn't sleep you know
we were up all night long thinking about
the game and thinking about the
opportunities that we would have during
that ball game he wanted some battles I
want some battles but there was a lot of
respect right back and and did he ever
tell did you know he had to tell her
where he put his feet or the way he
moved his hands or because I'm sure he
was watching you the same way yeah you
know what when Wendy on came over to the
San Francisco 49ers he was one of those
guys that laid his uniform out of the
serving way he always had these boxers
on that he's put on this regimen that
was his traditional thing like that but
man when this guy stepped on a football
field he was just I mean he was almost
like Superman and and what he was able
to do so Jerry Rice here on the Rich
Eisen show once the first time you met
Bill Walsh when you knew that you
remember the 49ers and here we go walk
me through that Jerry well when I got
that call from Bill Walsh and it was
like it was like a dream come true and
then to meet this guy and he has this
air about him and you know he was not
only a coach he was more you know he was
like a father to me and he gave me an
opportunity to go chase my dream and to
play for the San Francisco 49ers one of
the greatest dynasty ever you know it's
something I'll never forget and look
who's got the only remaining undefeated
record in the NFC right now in the 2019
football season Jerry
yeah three and oh right now and you know
last week you know they turned the ball
over on offense they had about five and
they got to go back and they got to make
those correction right if they do that
and I you know I think this team can you
know continue to win but it's just one
game at a time
who's the best receiver in the NFL today
Larry from its indc you put him up there
in terms of an all-time great the one
that you you think has got a tremendous
amount of talent young what have you
give me I think I think Julio Jones I
mean he's a beast on the football field
that can run by you he he's physical off
the line of scrimmage and you know he
can always position his body to make
difficult catch Jerry Rice here on the
Rich Eisen show tell me about the rice
and pasta Roni that your what what is
what's going on here with the San
Francisco treat right here well yeah you
just hit it right on the nose you know
rice-a-roni we we're both the San
Francisco treat and I have partnered
with writer Oney and I even thought
about changing my name to Jerry Rice
roster oneis no kidding
yeah you know think about that rich how
that would have looked on a Jersey and
you know we're tailgating in football is
going full force right now it was always
easy for me to run that perfect route or
you know make that win and catch or
something like that but what I like with
rice-a-roni they have so many variety
I mean varieties and another thing too
you know when I when I played the game
always had a go-to rich and you know
when it comes to tailgating it's a
jalapeno cheddar okay cuz I would might
be on the football field my man no
buckets your goal team right calm if you
want more info okay yeah and you go to
go team rice calm for more information
you can win prizes cash and and another
broad mooch I know would love at pasta
Roni he's all about the pasta Mariucci
is a funny guy man he dressed up as
someone you know aren't you yep yeah he
put on the jorts you put on the George
Jerry yeah but but I feel can't believe
moods been realized how many passes
Terrell Owens you know because I
remember I counted them it was about 20
and it was supposed to be my going-away
day
yeah Jerry you know we bring that up
with Steve all the time and I'm glad you
opened that door to allow it barge
through it sort of like the kool-aid guy
so you know we bring up the fact that on
Jerry Rice day he gave Terrell Owens so
many targets he caught 20 Jerry called
20 balls and I remember making that
presentation to a Terrell after the game
by giving him the game ball but it was
supposed to be my going-away day but
right you uh but you know moonship kept
saying that you know I didn't realize he
had called so many passes and I was like
yeah I knew you did communicate that in
a way Jerry like are we on the same
field mooch is one of the all-time
greats just a great human and Jerry Rice
good to chat with you we will chat with
you further down the line and thanks for
doing that for the for NFL the grind I
can't wait to see you out there with
Larry I saw you also playing golf with
them as well it's just uh it's neat on
off the field the whole thing it'll be
great
hey rich you know I took some money from
Larry right nope would you can I try to
get him to sign that that hundred dollar
bill but he wouldn't do it okay
there's there's still time Jerry they're
still right that's Jerry Rice here on
the Rich Eisen show at Jerry Rice on
Twitter at the Jerry Rice 80 on
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app